네. 안녕하세요. 오늘 빌사남옥 탐방
코너를 저희가 만들었습니다. 채널
분제 중이라는 유튜브를 운영하고 있고
지금 가장 핫한 크레이터들이 많이
소속되 있는 업체예요. 뭐 선수동의
사업을 올렸다고 해 가지고 제가 직접
찾아오게 됐습니다.이 4혹 탐방
코난는 BSN의 그 김례중개사님이랑
같이 진행할 예정인데 간단하게 인사
한번 좀 부탁드리겠습니다.
>> 안녕하세요. BSM 빌산남 중개법인
김수의 중개사입니다. 한번 본격적으로
좀 들어가서 한번 내부가 좀 어떤지
한번 들어가서 좀 보고 그다음에
대표님이 인터뷰도 살짝 해 주신다고
합니다. 그래서 인터뷰까지 같이
진행할 예정인데 들어가서 한번 어떻게
생겼는지 한번 좀 보도록 하겠습니다.
가시죠.
[음악]
>> 네. 어, 지하에 왔는데 친구가 엄청
높은 거 같아요. 그
>> 개방감이 진짜 좋네요.
>> 그래서 직원들 시기에 되게 좋게 돼
있고. 여기 뭐 다트하는데도
있네요.이
>> 기계 되게 비싼 건데.
>> 골드 버튼도 있네요. 여기
>> 그러니까 이게 100만. 저희는 언제
100만 될까요?
>> 저희도 곧 100만 되지 않을까요?
>> 소속되어 있는 유튜버들이신가 봐요.
네.
>> 네. 생각 없이 사는 연.
>> 어.이 이 그거 아니 욕은 아니죠.
그니까
그죠 방명록처럼
>> 방명록처럼 이렇게 오
>> 그다음에뭐
전자레지 있고
냉동식품이 있네요.
>> 오 복지가 너무 좋은 거 아니에요?
그런가?
가슴살이랑
>> 아 탁구칠 수 있게 이렇게
>> 네
>> 자연스럽네
대기하고 계시는데 저희 대표님 네
>> 오셨습니다.
>> 어디서 할까요?
>> 그 여기 앉아서 할까요?
>> 네네 저기 앉을까? 아, 네. 네.
좋습니다.
>> 네. 그리고 대표님 간단하게 소개좀
부탁드리겠습니다.
>> 네. 안녕하세요. 저는 그 글로우업
리즈라는 컨텐츠 회사 운영하고 있는
권기준이라고 합니다. 네,
>> 반갑습니다.
아, 그 제가 알고 있기로는 창업한지
그렇게 오래되지 않았는데 핫도그 TV
이제
>> 맞아요. 그때가 저 회실 하나 정도
한 일곱 여덟평 됐나요? 예. 그
정도 시작했습니다. 맨 처음에
사무실에 없었고요. 그다음에 구한게
이제 나라에서 창업지원 센터라는 데서
이제 소액을 지불하며 이제 빌려주는
그런 공간이 있어서 거기서 시작을
했어요. 예.
>> 그러니까 그래서 거기서 시작해서
어떻게 보면 지금 요렇게 4억까지 좀
얻게 되는데
>> 4억 매입하신지 얼마나 되셨어요?
>> 4억 계약한지 딱 1년 됐어요. 작년
7월에 계약했어요. 예. 제가 사업을
이제 매입한 이유가 다른 건물에 이제
임차로 있을 때 이제 영업적인 한계를
되게 많이 느꼈어요. 스케일업 하는데
이제 보여지는 것도 중요하다라는
생각을 저희가 어느 순간 딱 해서 아
그냥 한번 사 볼까 하고 인테리어
한번 해 볼까 해서 했는데 시선이 좀
많이 달라진게 있는 거 같고 아무리
제가 재무제표들이 대봤자네
>> 눈에 보이는 거 한 번이
끝나더라고요.
>> 면적도 제가 알고 있거 한 100평
대지간 100평대고 옆면적이 무려
한평 정도 되는 거서 건물 사이즈도
되게 큰 거 같거든요. 용적률도 거의
한 300% 좀 넘게 받은 건물인데
>> 네. 전 동현 무장이 훨씬 더
4억으로 쓰긴 적합하다라고 생각을
했고
>> 여기는 그리고 건물주가 일곱
명이었어요.
>> 아이 약간 분양상가처럼 그런
개념이었어서 필질을 하니까 탁감이 확
올라가더라고요. 그래서 그거 하고
뭐이 이거저것 좀 해 가지고 되게
저렴하게 잘 샀던 거 같아요. 회사
사업 소개를 하려면 저희 회사 소개를
좀 간단하게 드려야 될 것 같은데
>> 저희는 기본적으로 그 컨텐츠 비즈니스
하는 회사예요. 그래서 이제 컨텐츠를
자체적으로 제작을 잘해서 그 컨텐츠를
활용해서 이제 수입화를 시키는 이제
회사라고 보시면 되고
>> 그래서 회사의 전반적인 테마는 사실
크리에이터 영입에 초점이 거의 다
맞춰져 있어요. 크리에이터가 많을수록
저희가 또 좋은 브랜드를 붙여서 이걸
또 시너지를 내서 거기서 돈을 버는
회사기 때문에
>> 그렇다 보니까 여기 지하도 돈을 좀
많이 쓴 티가 나잖아요. 그래서 이런
거 그 유럽 미장 뭐 이런 거 해
가지고 그래서 크리에이터분들이 여기
왔을 때 일하고 싶다 혹은 뭐 이쁘다
사진 찍고 싶다라는 조점을 두기
위해서 회사 전반적인 컨셉이 그렇게
되어 있고요. 그래서 지하는
크리에이터들이 뭐 파티를 하거나
미팅을 하거나 뭐 촬영을 하거나
직원들이 여기서 뭐 식사를 하거나
하는 라운지 공간을 쓰고 있어요. 뭐
1층부터 6층까지 소개를 좀 간단히
드리자면
>> 네
>> 1층은 저희가 FMB 매장을 두 개를
넣었어요. 다 지경으로 하는 거고요.
하나는 이제 외부 바깥에 접촉하면은
우동집으로 이제 간단하게 좀 이제
직장의 상권이니까 예, 좀 넣어 봤고
뒤에 오마카세를 넣었어요.
>> 예, 2층은 헬스장이에요. 운동
콘텐츠를 명분 삼아서 이제 외브
크리에이터들이랑 콜라보 촬영을 할 수
있게끔 이제 만들어 놓은 거예요.
3, 4층은 저희 내부 직원 공간으로
예, 5층은 좀 특이한데 쇼룸으로
만들어 놨어요. 저희가 이제 같이
하고 있는 브랜드들을 다 이제
올리브형보다 더 화려한 공간으로
만들어서 크리에이터가 딱 왔을 때
눈이 딱 돌게 휘둥굴해지게 이제
만들어지게끔 이제 좀 만들어서 거기
있는 제품이랑
>> 크리에이터를 매칭해 주는 이제
서비스를 저희가 하는 건데
>> 어 5층은 쇼름은 그렇게 구성을 해
놨고
>> 6층은 이제 헤드오피스를 쓰고
있습니다.
>> 너무 좋게
내부가 궁금한데 한번 위로 올라가서
직접 보도록 하겠습니다. 가시죠.
[음악]
그래서 지금 1층에 왔는데 여기가
이제 우동집인 거죠?
>> 네. 맞아요.
>> 오마카세 셰프 님이 두 개 다
운영하고 계예. 요걸 프랜차이즈화
시키고 싶으셔서
>> 저희랑 같이 하시게 된 거라서
>> 아 본점으로 요걸 시작으로 이제 계속
만들어 나가 볼 거 같고어 가격도
되게 저렴한 거 같아요.
>> 맞아요. 저희가 일단 여기 직장인
상권이다 보니까 일단 사람들이 한번
먹게 하면 그다음부터 계속 오겠다
싶어서 해봤는데 마케팅 하나도 안
했는데 점심에 계속 꽉 차요. 매일
아침 새벽에 국물을 오르세요.
>> 그니까 보통 요즘에 이제 우동도 한
만 원 하거든요. 무조건맞아.
7,000원 8,000원 해서 진짜
엄청 잘
>> 못 올리신 이유는 아직 우리의
서비스가 완벽하지 않다.
>> 그래서 아직 올릴 수가 없다.
오마카세도 똑같아요. 되게이 입지
치고 되게 저렴하게 하고 있어.
>> 오마카세는 얼마예요? 혹시
>> 런치가 7만 원, 비너가 13만 원.
>> 그렇게 안 비싸네.
>> 예. 엄청 저렴한 거죠. 사실.
>> 어, 저기 뒤쪽에 있는 거죠?
>> 한번 보실까요? 예. 한번 가시죠.
예.
[음악]
아 여기는 이제
>> 네
>> 룸이
이렇게
>> 스팅도 많이 하고 하니까
>> 어
>> 어 좌석이 꽤 많네요.
>> 예 열석 정도 될 거 같아.
>> 음
>> 원래는 그냥 1층이 40평 정도로
하나로 이렇게 돼 있었는데 20평
20평에서 반식쪽
>> 셰프님 인터뷰도 좀 할까요? 어님
>> 예
>> 인터뷰 한번만 해 주실 수 있지?
좀 했어. 밥 먹고 와가지고
>> 아 예 감사합니다. 매일 뭐 새벽 뭐
4시 반에 이제 노량진 가서 막
이렇게
>> 예 새벽은 새벽은 맞아요. 근데 조금
항상 여기 대표님이 조금 30분
당겨서 얘기하시
>> 5시
>> 매일 예일 시험 가서 물건을 이제
팔약만큼만 항상 준비해서 그렇게
영업하고 있어요. 전에 대표님을
아시다가 이렇게
>> 대표님은 손님으로 오신 거고 마포에
있을 때 저는 그때 이제 셋시하는
그냥 조그만 이제 사장이었고 그렇게
이제 손님하고 이렇게 만났다가 인년이
돼서 하게 됐어요.
>> 아 후하시
>> 아닙니다.
>> 스시지은 사실 그냥 너무 좋은
환경에서 다른 환경에서 하는 거라
일도 재밌고 뭐 음식도 당연히 뭐
퀄리티도 많이 올라가는 건 사실인데
많이 찾아봐 주셨으면 좋겠고 그리고
또 중요한 거 우동집 런칭하는데
>> 아까 얘기하신 대로 가격이 너무
좋아요. 조금 편하게 식사하시고
이렇게 가실 수 있게끔 좀 대종적으로
좀 많이 좀 알리고 싶은게 사실
오동집이거든요. 제 입장에서는.
>> 여기 당연히 모시면 너무 좋지만
>> 아무튼 가격이 싸다고 음식은 절대
싸진 않아요. 정말 진심이 많이
들어가 있기 때문에
>> 한 번 정도 좀 방문해 주시라 말씀
>> 네. 인터뷰 감사합니다.
>> 아, 고맙습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 아,
>> 감사합니다.
[음악]
>> 아, 라커도 있네요. 아니, 이제
웬만한 저기 PT샵보다 더 좋은데요.
>> 아니, 기계 이거 되게 비싼 것들
많은데요. 저도 소소하게 운동은 하고
있는데 이런 장비들은 되게 처음
봤어요. 좋은 거는
>> 저도 쓸 줄 몰라요. 아.
>> 어. 여기 피플릭 님이 운영하고
계시다고 들었는데
>> 저희 회사로 이제 같이 넘어오신
거고.
>> 네.
>> 운영은 이제 회사에서 하고 있고
플리님이랑 같이 이제
크리에이터분들이랑 같이 콜라보고 예.
그런 용도 만들어왔어요.
>> 아, 제가 원래 그 뭐야 피플리 님을
몰랐다가
>> 누가 유튜브 댓글에 그런 닮았다고
왜
>> 가지고 어
>> 그때 알게 됐어요.
>> 아무튼 그렇습니다. 3층 가봅시다.
>> 아니, 거의 꿈의 직장인데요. 아,
>> 그래요?
>> 그럼 뭐예요? 얼굴 많이 하시는데.
>> 아, 그래?
나중에 잘하면 또 올려주시거든가.
>> 제가 또 감시에 최적화된 자리를
만들어 가지고
>> 아. 아, 이게 딱 한 눈에 볼 수
있네. 이렇게 볼 수 있
>> 모니터 다 이쪽으로.
>> 맞아요. 맞아요. 맞아요.
>> 고민을 되게 많이 하신 거고.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 여기 컴퓨터는 한 몇대 정도
들어와요?
>> 네,서 몇대 정도 들어갈 거예요,
>> 노트북 쓰진 않죠?
>> 노트북 안 쓰고요. 다 듀얼
>> 듀얼이고 바닥을 이렇게 소리 많이 안
나도록 이렇게 깔아 놓으신 거?
>> 아니. 아니야. 그냥 있어 보이려고
>> 아 그냥 이렇게네
>> 있어 보이잖아
>> 세가 되게 자유로운 편이라서 자고
있잖아요 실에서
>> 아
>> 예 스넥바가 있고요. 그래서 뭐 반
정도는 지금 PD 님들 있고 반
정도는 이제
>> 비즈니스 T 되게 자유로운 편이에요.
분위기가
>> 음
>> 조금 구조가 좀 3층이랑 4층 살짝
다른데 거의 비슷네
>> 일주일에 보통 영상 몇 개
제작하세요? 한 다섯 개에서 한 일곱
개 아 근데 이게 저희가 자체적으로
제작하는 것도 있고
>> 외부의 채널을 컨트롤하는 것도 있어서
자체적으로 편집하고 PD로서의 기능들
있는 것만 나머지는 저희가 컨설팅을
하는 역할이 좀 더 많아요.
>> 아고 또 위로 올라가서 5층이 이제
그거잖아요. 제품 예되는데
[음악]
>> 와 제품이 진짜 많네요.네 네. 진짜
다양하게 많다. 보통 이렇게
크레이터분들이 나 이거 꼭 팔고 싶어
하는게 있을까요? 요
>> 줄 있죠?요 세 번째 줄.요
>> 라인이 제일 인기 많은 라인이에요.
>> 시선이 딱 제일 많이 가는 데를
>> 아 그렇게 또 하셨구나.
>> 네. 제일 많이 가는 것들
>> 뭐지 이거?
>> 데스키라고요?
>> 진동 클렌저 이런 거
>> 진동 클렌저.
>> 아
>> 그래서 뭐 어떤 거는 한번 컨텐츠
나오면 한 2억 5천 뭐 이렇게
팔리는 것도 있고.
>> 아 한번 팔 때요? 아,
>> 저기 이제 리빙 뭐 아, 리빙이 가장
좋
>> 다 있다고 보시면 돼요.
>> 되게 다양하게 취급을 하시네요. 오,
>> 다 있어요.
>> 아니, 웬만한 매장보다 더 많은 거
같아요.
>> 브랜드 요청해서 이렇게 받아 놓고
크레이터 딱 왔을 때
>> 네. 바로 그냥 매칭을 시키는 작전
채널마다
>> 타겟도 다르고 뭐 연령대도 다르고
선호하는 바가 다 달라서 채널마다 그
특징에 맞게끔 제한을 드려요. 여긴
R&D에 저희가 샘플들 들어오면
테스트해서 같이 먹어 봐야 되기도
하고요. 밀키트를 많이 파니까
밀키티지 같이 해서 먹어보고 너무
좋다.
그래서 이렇게 만들어 놔야 이렇게
계약 성세율도 되게 높아지고
>> 맞아요.
[음악]
>> 네. 여기가 이제 6층이고
>> 6층 저희 헤드오피를 쓰고 있게
경영지원실이고 저희 부사장님 강이고
여기 제방 쓰고 있습니다.
>> 아 대표님 방 한번 보시하셔. 아
여기
>> 어 이거 여기 납드셨네요. 이
>> 크레이터 사인할 때 하려고
>> 아 잘하셨네. 이거
>> 어
>> 이걸로 꼭 사인하세요. 크레이터
>> 그러니까요.
>> 어 여기 방주도 너무 좋네요.
>> 여기도
>> 네. 인테리어 할 때 업체에서 아니
대표실이면 좀 쇼파도 넣고 좀 해라
했는데 저는
>> 다 필요 없고 여기서 회의 제일 많이
할 거니까 책상 제일 큰 거 넣어
주세요 해가지고이 이거 없고
>> 진짜 일하는 대표 사무실처럼 같다고
하시더라고요.
>> 어 이거 이거는 왜 9단 하셨어요?
>> 이거는 뭐 의미는 없고요. 제가
예전에 컨텐츠 했을 때 했었던
소품인데요. 그냥 버리기 아까워서도
거예요. 그냥 아무 의미 없습니다.
>> 괜찮은데요. 9단주님
>> 뭐 있어 보이잖아요. 그죠? 있어
보는게 중요하기 때문에 또 저희는
아요
>> 각서는 뭐예요? 앞서 저희
크리에이터들이 콘텐츠 찍다가 이제 한
건데
>> 아
>> 이제 커플 채널이 있는데
>> 네
>> 1년 동안 결혼 안 하면 둘이
헤어지는 걸로
>> 아
>> 예 그런 콘텐츠가 또 있었어 가지고
>> 제가 또 각서 써 주고 증인으로
제가네
>> 아마이 영상을 그 사혹을 되게
꿈꾸시는 분들도 보실 거 같아요.
그래서 만약에 사혹 찾는 분들한테
한마디 해 주신다라고 하면은
>> 이제 저가 살 때 김윤수 대표님이
이제 저한테 무리하는 거 아니냐 좀
너무 과한데요. 이렇게 말씀 많이
해주셨는데 저 이제 하이스 하이
리턴이라고 저 생각을 하고이자
>> 낼 수 있는 뭔가 탄탄한 비즈니스가
갖춰져 있으면 전 좀 던져봐도 되지
않나라고 조심스럽게 진짜 예 말씀을
드리고 싶고
>> 어쨌든 저 90% 대출 받았거든요.
딱히 이전에는게 그렇게 저희한테
부담스러운 상황 아니었어서
>> 리스크가 별로 없을 것 같은데라고
생각을 해서 했는데 결과적으로 어쨌든
지금 시점에서 1년 지나고 보니까
많이 올랐어서 황금성이 일단 가장
중요하다. 예. 유튜브 보면서 항상
공부하는게 황금성
>> 음
>> 청담 앞구정 뭐 강남에 다시 팔릴
만한데 그리고 성수 용산 한남 뭐요
정도 보시는 걸 가장 추천드리고
>> 그 외에 이제 지역들은 예 아무래도
똑같은 가격 대비 현금성이 떨어지지
않 않나라는 이제 생각이 저도 들어서
사실 팔 걸 생각하고 사시면 좋을 것
같아요.
>> 나이도 좀 어린 편이고 하다 보니까
사기꾼은 진짜 절대 아니고요. 정도를
항상 걸어서 사업을 해 왔고 그래서
그렇게 보지 않아 주셨으면 좋겠고
글로 리즈라는 저희 회사 되게
나름대로 탄탄하고 1천억 밸류 투자
유치를 앞두고 있거든요. 그리고
빌사남과 또 저희 리즈가 함께 또
운동 사업할 날을 전 기다리고
있으니까
>> 아네네 조만간에 한번
말씀드리겠습니다.
자 그래서 오늘 첫 번째 게스트로 와
주셨는데네 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요. 다음 시간에도 뵙도록
하겠습니다. 감사합니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]